we begin this hour with the continuing
effort by many to leave afghanistan the
u.s and its coalition forces pulled out
in august after 20 years of war there
the taliban took over shortly after the
sudden collapse of the afghan government
for those afghans who got out the next
hurdle is to start a new life but for
others they must continue to wait mts
taya reports from kabul
it's the first big step in a new life
these afghans mostly families consider
themselves the lucky ones as they check
in for an evacuation flight to qatar
just getting to this point for so many
afghans has been extraordinarily
difficult and now
they have to take the next big step in
their journey
it's a journey nabi roshan is taking
with his young family he hosted a
nightly political satire show in
afghanistan where no one not even the
taliban was off limits but after the
group seized power in august roshan says
there's little left to laugh about
do the taliban like jokes
i don't think
so
did you receive any threats
i don't know just say
i
i will
kill you
maybe
so many more afghans fear the same fate
like sammy not his real name
he was a translator for the u.s military
in the southern city of kandahar the
birthplace of the taliban since the
group seized control of the country in
august he and his young family have been
hiding in kabul waiting for what's known
as a special immigrant visa to the u.s
the u.s government has said they're
trying to speed up this application
process has it been happening for you no
it's not you've been hiding in a rented
apartment here in kabul now for three
months how long can you survive like
this
i can't survive
america's longest war couldn't have been
fought without afghans from translators
to gathering intelligence many tens of
thousands assisted in the fight working
with u.s forces through thick and thin
the biden administration has faced
mounting criticism for not making it
easier for an estimated 100 000 afghans
who have supported the u.s mission to
get visas out and while the taliban
insists its forces won't harm anyone who
once worked for the united states as
part of what it's calling a general
amnesty many afghans like sammy
just don't believe themselves i'm not
happy here in the shelter of
taliban
why not if they took me if they captured
me they will kill me
a fear that's only growing with every
passing day
for cbs saturday morning i'm impions
tayam in kabul